hey Rick we have see Randy from Cornell
continue on transportation thank you
good okay great so thank you very much
for the invitation and yeah I guess Rick
was mentioning this is somewhat a
continuation of the previous talk in
multiple senses so I'm also at Cornell
and so but this was work which I did
when I was at Stanford as a postdoc and
so it's a joint work with Rami shahuri
at Stanford northa Carles Academy who's
a graduate student in the ICM II group
at Stanford but perhaps at least
definitely want to draw your attention
to the last line so the big big credit
for the work goes to the data science
team at lift and the way it came about
was we had been playing around with some
of these problems and we just happen to
be at the right place at the right time
and this was 2014 and lyft just started
trying to think about doing dynamic
pricing and we thought we could solve it
in our usual hubris and so if said sure
come over solve it and then I so I sort
of spent a summer working at lyft
actually writing out their dynamic
pricing stuff and I think the one thing
I learned is like real systems are just
nothing close to what we think they are
in the models are there were all sorts
of strange things going on when we were
initially playing around with it and at
some point of time we sort of figured
out something which started working
really really well
and did a lot of a/b tests compared it
to static pricing and and it still
seemed to do very well so then what this
work is is it's going to be different
from most of the other talks in that
there is no data there is a big reason
that there's no data in particular there
is a certain Big Brother sitting around
the room who are not in the room but
around who answered exchanging data for
any of these companies is pretty tricky
but really the point of this talk is at
least how we think about dynamic pricing
and
sharing platforms and why we think it
seems to work very well but sort of on a
broader level what are the interesting
problems that are coming about in the
sort of next wave of online marketplaces
and what why I think we have the right
tools for solving some of this so before
I even jump into right sharing this is a
quote so I think Microsoft published
this have this website earlier in this
year where they asked all the top people
in Microsoft what do you think are going
to be like the top developments in 2016
this is Preston McAfee who I think is
the chief economist at Microsoft he is
not surprisingly talking about economics
the thing which I like and I'm I'm
definitely biased in this regard is what
he says right at the end about uber and
the fact that in some sense a lot of
people in all the excitement about all
the data that is being released in all
these marketplaces they tend to overlook
the fact that something one really
really unique aspect of these new
companies is that their marketplaces so
there is a sort of wave of companies
coming in and trying to enter into
various aspects of of just economic life
or like day-to-day interaction but
instead of doing it in a conventional
way they are doing it in this way of
setting up a marketplace essentially
defining the rules of the game and then
of letting it play out and an uber lyft
Airbnb are perhaps like the standard
bearers of this but there many other
interesting problems in this regard and
in some sense what I am really
interested in and what I'd like to
encourage a lot of people to start
thinking about is what I think is a road
of real-time decision-making in these
new online marketplaces and in
particular there's if you talk to an
economist about this or if you talk to a
lot of people there is a sense in which
there's nothing new which is going on we
have seen all of this before economics
has solved all these problems they're
slightly different but it does feel to
me that by saying that we are sort of
somewhat missing a crucial point that
that there are certain specific features
of these marketplaces which I don't
think have been seen before and
at least to me it's not obvious that all
of this collapses to everything that we
know about online marketplaces now I
mean give this excellent talk about add
options today and in some sense we could
have before like in the early days of ad
auction said that we know everything
about auctions let's just run it but
there is a sense in which the theory
community has made a very very
fundamental contribution in how ad
options are thought about and and I do
feel that in many of these new
marketplaces perhaps not all but in many
of them there will be sort of new
challenges which come about especially
because we have these are new
technologies for monitoring and
controlling these systems and now I
don't think we will have maybe an
overarching theory there are a lot of
interesting sort of theories about
dynamic mechanism design which I mean
was mentioning but I do think many of
these marketplaces have sort of
interesting eccentricities which you
need to sort of target differently on
and you can get very rich problems from
these settings and so that's kind of the
high levels context within which I was
going to place this work we did on
rideshare platforms in particular the
thing which got us very interested in
right share platforms well firstly I
come from a queueing then queueing
background and this seemed like this
should be a queuing network but there is
a really really odd thing about these
platforms which is quite different from
many others which is that it is one of
these rare markets where the platform
sets the transaction price now we could
argue why this is the case we have all
this amazing theory about optimal
mechanism design why do we not just run
a second-price auction between drivers
and passengers one week argument here is
that that was tried there was a company
called sidecar which tried doing that
where people could put up prices and
like people could like choose who they
wanted to go with notice the operative
word was in the previous sentence it
seems like it doesn't work and the
reason people think it doesn't work is
in some sense whatever and lift up
providing you is just transportation
it's a taxi service I don't want to
solve an optimization problem when I ask
for it
see when I asked for a rental car should
I spend some time doing it I sort of go
through all my options when I do airline
tickets yes when I get out of a
restaurant and I want a taxi I want it
fast I want a sort of low friction
environment and and all the companies in
the space have very quickly sort of
gravitated to this point where there's
almost no friction you press a button a
car comes by you're happy with it and of
course in doing that you've sort of
taken away a lot of the control of our a
lot of the power of the marketplace to
do optimization and in some sense the
platform has taken it onto themselves
and that's the thing that we are
interested in now I'm hoping most of you
have used lyft or uber but in case you
haven't this is roughly how it works so
the way these ride-sharing marketplaces
work it's a set of paired apps this is
the view that a passenger gets so as a
passenger you sort of sign on to these
platforms in the case of lift yes yes
and I'll come to that okay we could
argue about that but there is something
fundamental so okay I I think I'm I'm
using that to make a distinction that
this is the marketplace this is not
someone who's employed the driver is not
employed by the company a drivers really
an independent agent who can choose when
to work where to work if to work so uber
and lyft are not taxi companies in the
sense that they do not except in New
York City are employ people they just
said the rules of the game and let it
play out
and that's what we want to look at
question um but okay so the way it works
for a passenger is that you open the app
you see a bunch of vehicles around you
you're basically given an estimate of
when the nearest vehicle is and there's
are various modes you can choose you
request a ride you get matched up with a
rider you take the ride at the end of
the ride you are quoted or you are told
the price of the right now there's a
standard formula which is available on
the website for each city it's basically
just some constant plus a linear
function of distance and time
and you paid this and you go on your way
it's completely frictionless you if you
don't want to you really don't have to
deal much with the driver you can give
destination online so so a lot of the
benefit of these platforms is in that
they're completely reducing the friction
of taking a taxi ride you don't have to
stand at the street corner and compete
with people you don't have to I can
decide how much tips to give etcetera
etcetera or you don't have to feel guilt
in giving or not giving tips all of that
friction has been removed so that's a
huge advantage but the thing which in
some sense seems to get much more
present sort of why people think these
platforms are doing really well is the
fact that because the platforms have
taken the the ability to charge prices
on to themselves they can actually now
charge dynamic prices so how does
dynamic pricing work as I was saying the
formula for the price of a ride is some
linear function of the distance and the
time plus some extra fees in addition at
the beginning of the ride in this screen
you will also be told if you are in
primetime or not or if there is surge
pricing or not and so the app will tell
you a priori that if you want a ride
right now you are going to pay 25% more
than the regular fare or 1.25 times the
regular cell and and this is how it
looks like when you in at the end of the
ride this person took a ride on January
31st at 12:35 clearly a time when you
there is much more demand and supply and
so they actually got quite lucky in that
there was only 25% prime time this is a
pretty old picture and so this was the
extra amount of debate
so I mean if you start reading about any
of these ride-sharing platforms at least
in the popular media there is a sense in
which this is the thing which will
completely rule the world the fact that
they can do prime dynamic pricing
clearly gives them this huge advantage
and sort of embedded in that narrative
is the story that it's obvious dynamic
pricing can give you a huge advantage I
mean duh it's like economics 101 and I
don't think it's that obvious now
there's a subtlety in the way dynamic
pricing is done which is that now it is
clearly obvious that the demand is not
the same at different times of the day
so you should be during the morning rush
hour there's much more demand than
supply in the afternoon there's much
less demand than supply
however a lot of this is actually quite
predictable so you you know that during
the morning rush hour you may not know
exactly but you do know that there's
much more demand than in the afternoon
and the idea of actually charging
different prices in the morning rush
hour or in the afternoon or at night
that's actually not new so I mean I
remember as far back as when I was
growing up in India when you took a taxi
ride at night you used to pay 50% extra
or something like that and this was
mandated this was part of the sort of
fee structure agreed on by the
government that you're going to pay more
at times of greater demand so the point
of dynamic pricing and I think this is
what a lot of people think about it is
that it's not that you can charge
different prices at different times of
the day that's clearly a win-win but
that can be done even by taxis you could
always have a sort of a schedule of
rates that you charge at different times
on the day now the thing that people
don't realize or I think by now a lot of
people do realize that lyft and uber
actually change prices on a much faster
time scale so it's on the order of
minutes maybe even faster now and on
something like a three block by three
block radius or maybe even smaller so so
you're really doing dynamic pricing on a
very very fine range of geographical and
time basis and at that point it's not
obvious to me why exactly is this doing
better so you in some sense you are not
reacting to these sort of large-scale
changes in the average demand you are
reacting to stochastic fluctuations
and you're doing it in a system which is
sort of a complex where rights are taken
up there and somewhere it's the number
of drivers keeps changing etc etc it's
not immediately obvious that dynamic
pricing is buying you anything and so
that was the problem we went in to try
and look at so this is a graph of or
this is a map of San Francisco it's from
this website called watch the fair which
actually like collects quote or prime
time quotes from these companies or you
can query both the companies to see what
the prices are and it sort of collects
this data or at least used to and you
can see that okay during the morning
rush hour most of the demand is in the
outskirts there's less demand downtown
it's sort of reverses in the evening so
this is actually showing the prime time
but in some sense the prime time is
reacting to or the average prices are
reacting to the average demand which is
actually quite predictable I don't have
data to back this up but the companies
do have pretty decent demand predictions
about a prediction about the demand
there's also a sort of hidden thing
about these systems that unlike
bike-sharing there's actually no sensor
demand in lift ANOVA so the friction in
opening your app and looking for a ride
is really really small so you're
actually seeing everyone who is on
you're seeing most people who are
looking for a ride you're seeing exactly
what's the time and price they were
quoted you can form very good models of
whether they wanted a ride or not this
is all very predictable but the question
is why should we then sort of do this
dynamic and I'm using the word quasi
static to sort of distinguish that
really what I want to compare this fine
brain type of fine time scale dynamic
pricing is with something which reacts
to the average changes or the average
demand and the average elasticity's in a
time period so not a price which remains
constant throughout the day but
something which like we could just for
the purposes of this talk and for this
work what I'm imagining is that the
demand remains constant for some time
then it changes its its block Markov and
and we can change the price to react to
that or we can change the price to react
to stochastic fluctuations what I'm
trying to ask is what is the latter
buying you over the former
and immediately once you formulate the
question you realize that in order to
try and address this question it's not
sufficient to just think about the
strategic behavior of passengers and
drivers you also really need a model
which captures the dynamics of the
platform so you cannot talk about fine
time scale dynamic pricing without
actually having some sort of dynamic
model for the platform and that for me
is excellent because my backgrounds in
queueing theory and clearly this should
be a queuing model and that's where
we're going to go to but you also in
addition to the dynamics you do need to
the control that you're doing is through
market mechanism you're controlling
things through price and so you really
need to think about the strategic
behavior of both the passengers and the
drivers and this is coming back to your
question that the drivers are not
employed by the platform they have the
agency to join or not join the platform
and you also want to think about why is
the platform choosing these policies
what are their objectives and what can
they do and what I'll sort of try to
convince you is that a lot of you can
come up with models which seem which
seem sort of to model a lot of these
phenomena but they still somewhat
tractable and kind of surprisingly what
at least we get when we think about this
problem is that there's a sense in which
doing this our dynamic pricing over the
stochastic fluctuation is not
fundamentally better than static pricing
so they'll if I was of completely
omniscient and I could choose exactly
the right price there is an exact right
price which I could have chosen for each
time of the day but there's a sense in
which it is buying you a lot of
robustness or it is sort of learning
certain parameters and kind of smoothing
over the fact that maybe you can't
predict everything exactly or maybe
there are sort of unexpected events
which you can't take care of so the
reason why at least we think at the end
of this exercise and this is the
completely theoretical exercise but we
know dynamic pricing and practice works
really well we posit that the reason for
that is not that it is fundamentally
better but it is sort of much more
robust compared to doing anything static
that's what I try to talk about
I'm kind of from in terms of where this
work fits in there's actually a very
nice literature which started roughly
around 2003 by Roshan Tyrol and followed
up by a bunch of other people aren't
thinking about two-sided marketplaces
and the idea that in many of these
two-sided marketplaces if I enter a
marketplace like lyft or Airbnb in
addition to the price that I'm charged
by the marketplace it's also very
important to know who else enters on the
other side of the marketplace so so the
simplest story is if you are in a dating
market sure they charge your
subscription you decide whether to pay
that or not but you also decide whether
to enter based on how many people
entered on the other side who are
deciding whether to enter based on how
many people enter on this side and vice
versa so in order to actually say
something about these markets you really
want to think about the equilibrium that
emerges from this this game and
understand the role and while and a
bunch of other people sort of came up
with a bunch of face stylized economic
models about how she you should think
about these marketplaces and on the
other hand there is a sort of older
stream of literature on revenue
management I'm very rich literature and
revenue management in particular there's
this seminal work by Geico and one
rising all the way back in 94 where they
were thinking of something like airline
pricing you have a bunch of seats and
you want to sort of price them against a
stochastic demand and we came up they
basically came up with a sub optimal way
of doing dynamic pricing if you exactly
knew the demand and the long line of
work following on from that but the
crucial assumption in all those works is
that your resources are given to you at
the beginning of yourself given an
endowment of airline seats and you're
trying to decide what best to do and so
one of the surprising things that comes
about is that okay again when rise and
actually made a very similar observation
that in an appropriate limit there is a
single static price but dynamic pricing
again in that setting seems to by this
sense of robustness and it's for
completely different reasons and one of
the things which we are still trying to
figure out is like what really are the
connection between why are we getting
something similar and I'm kind of
putting a bunch of other work so there
is a lot of progress more recently in
in networks where we can model richer
queuing networks what I have done what
we have used is actually a much older
model of what are called Jackson
networks but there are bunch there are
many other settings which are better
modeled by many of these newer so
stochastic models which we have and I
think there are a lot of interesting
questions about how we can fit these to
serve real market places and how we can
control them ok so that's the background
ok what exactly are we doing in our work
well so we are going to just focus on a
single block of time so think of this as
the morning rush hour and a single
region so morning rush hour downtown San
Francisco and the main idea over here is
that we're going to assume that all the
mean system parameters stay constant so
there is some sort of average demand
there's an average supply of drivers
there's sort of these price elasticity
functions cost elasticity functions all
of this remains constant in this block
of time this is of course a vase of
simplified assumption but we sort of go
with this and see what we can say in
this case and in particular what we are
going to do under this assumption is
we're gonna track we are going to build
a stochastic model to track the number
of free drivers in the system so how
many drivers are waiting around in this
region for someone to come and give a
ride to take a ride and for simplicity
ok now what I mean by dynamic pricing
here is since I'm keeping track of the
number of available drivers this is an
instantaneous state variable which is
keep which is continuously changing over
time and I'm going to set a price for a
ride at any time or this multiplier for
the ride as a function of the available
drivers at that instant in the network
I'm also going to assume that the
platform on the fixed fraction of every
dollar spent so this is how it's done
right now it's unclear if this is
optimal but just to keep things simple
that's what we're going to assume that's
the high level story of the model to
kind of the main thing which is going to
drive all of our results and and this is
something which I think is fairly
fundamental in this setting but is also
true in many other settings is that
there is a fundamental difference in the
time scale on which the two sides react
to the marketplace so if I am a person
just got out of a restaurant I'm not
sure of reasoning over the long time to
decide whether I want a taxi ride or not
like how much money do I have should I
save it up should I invest it in stocks
no I just look at the price and go what
do I want the taxi or not on the other
hand and this is something which we can
test looking at data the drivers are
definitely sensitive to their long-term
earnings so they don't care about
whether this instantaneous ride is under
search pricing or not I mean initially
some drivers care but the way soon
realize that there's no point trying to
predict that what they really care about
is at the end of the day or at the end
of the week are we making enough money
to make this worthwhile harder maybe we
have an outside option oh sorry yeah on
the road yeah I don't believe it's true
so the typical time I mean just sort of
as a thought experiment the time it
would take you to react to search
pricing and go somewhere would be on the
order of 10 or 15 minutes the prices are
changing every minute now
that's not that's not proof one of the
things which I can say is a both lift
and / I've done a lot of experimentation
with what they call heat maps so they
show the drivers what the search looks
like and as far as I know both are sort
of unconvinced if this is doing
something which they know and definitely
if you just show prices there is a sense
in which drivers miss coordinate so
initially they start driving towards the
heat and then they go it's gone they
sort of go somewhere else if you talk to
most drivers after a point they just
sort of stop looking at it they know in
their head that certain areas are good
certain areas are bad at certain times
of the day and they just follow that so
that they're not reacting to things
instantaneously so it's not that that is
untrue but I'm going to try and claim
that it's that it's true in a more
subtle sense it's true in an equilibrium
sense but not on an instantaneous sense
another thing you may sort of take issue
with or someone may take issue with is
I'm saying that drivers are sensitive to
long term average earnings you could ask
well how exactly are they learning this
long term average earnings this is
actually made very simple by lyft and
uber they actually send out a mail every
week to all the drivers which
basically says this is how much money
you made Ober saying you could have
earned 217 dollars more but really what
they are the information they're giving
is these are the times of the week and
this is how much money drivers made at
different times of the week so as the
driver you have complete freedom to
choose when you want to work where you
want to work and in particularly if you
want to work at all is it worthwhile at
all to work on the system or not so it's
like instead of really sort of thinking
about learning dynamics this of just
shortcutting it this giving you the
information and saying do you want to
work or not never seen they drive the
site before Starfire fascinating and
what's the basis for that 217 I don't
know I don't know and I'd be a little
scared if there is a exact answer or not
but I mean you could sort of calculate
on the basis of this would be my
conjecture they're looking at how many
hours you drove and then they sort of
saying if you had shifted it a bit and
driven in other us assuming everything
else is a constant I know how much Drive
was made on average and those other arts
so even just assuming this at least
that's our first cut I would do that
assuming you drive the same number of
hours but shifted it a bit how much more
would you make I think you can still
take deeper into those and they do give
you more information but I'm not I will
search you never see in the driver side
so I'm not sure I can't either so this
is not from lift lift is again they
don't really publish this this is from a
third party but it's very similar it's
sort of saying there are ours and they
sort of saying what was the average
value people made drivers made in those
are the drivers in the same region so
there's another sort of website where
you can go where they'll break it down
by region so it should you drive an SF
should be drive and that is definitely
driver heterogeneity so I've I've talked
with drivers who had like back problems
and so they don't want to drive during
the Russia because they don't want to be
stationary for too long or people who
just don't like the Russia and things
like that or or have kids and want to go
back home
yeah I'm sure they'd be tested that and
found out this is best so I'm not gonna
defend this exactly I'm just sort of
using this to say that there is a sense
in which a lot of the learning a
short-circuit information is given back
to the drivers and drivers can act upon
that so how should we fit this into the
model so this is how I think of the
ride-sharing system so I'm imagining a
queue of or just a birth-death chain of
the number of available drivers in a
region and I'm imagining that that
number is increasing at some rate lambda
now where does this lambda come from
hold on a second so it's increasing at
some rate so force on rate lambda on the
other hand there is a rate mu naught of
passengers arriving to the system
looking for a ride so this is just
people opening their app looking for a
ride now when they do that they are sort
of shown two things firstly they're
shown how far the driver is in my case
I'm just assuming dition is there a
driver there or not so I'm sort of
making that binary but they're also
shown a price and my assumption is that
each passenger has some distribution
over the value for the ride so they're
drawing the value iid then they look at
the price and go yeah okay sure my value
is higher I'm in the tail so I will take
it all I want so you take this mu naught
which is the actual rate of arrivals and
the new sort of winnowing it down using
these prices and the pricing policy I'm
going to think of is a really simple one
where I have a threshold on the number
of drivers if there are more drivers
than that I'm going to charge a lower
price so this Q actually drains much
faster as soon as I sort of hit this
threshold I charge a higher price it
slows down the queue this is so the
passenger side and passengers I mean if
they'd see a price they don't like or
they sin no drivers they just leave the
system so it's a blocking system as far
as they're concerned
clear just from the passenger side okay
so what's going on with the drivers well
we can take the same model and kind of
embed it in a larger queueing Network so
what i'm doing here is these were the
available drivers every time they got
matched up so this is what's called a MM
n1q if you're interested when whenever
they get matched up they basically give
a ride so if there's some busy time we
can model it however you feel like this
doesn't actually matter that much this
is a crucial assumption which we make
which is that at the end of the ride
that drivers independent with some
probability QX it just decide to get out
of the system so turn of the Raps
else they come back now there is
evidence that this does not happen
independently it happens based on
whether is a prime-time blah blah blah
but but in some sense this is a really
really noisy process because again many
of these drivers are both on lyft and
uber so they may just switch apps or
maybe they just wanted a coffee so in
some sense you definitely see drivers
going in and out and to simplify things
I'm modeling them a sort of exiting
independently and sort of entering at a
certain rate every King theorist in the
room is going no that's not why you're
doing it you're doing that because it's
a Jackson Network which is also true I
am sort of deliberately setting it up in
such a way such that this model is easy
to analyze and the reason I'm doing that
is now once I set it up I can go back
and as the question where why are the
drivers entering into the system and one
of typical way of thinking about it is
that the driver has some minimum rate of
earnings that they want to have so they
have a reservation
earning rate we could think of this as
this is the other work they could have
done maybe they could have worked
somewhere else in that time they would
have earned something they need a
certain minimum amount before they even
interested in entering the platform so
each driver there's this sort of mass
lambda knot of drivers who can join the
platform each one of them is making an
endogenous entry decision they know what
the average value they're going to make
based on that they're deciding should we
come in or not and the way I am
calculating that is as follows so each
driver has an individual earning rate
now what they're going to calculate is
for each pile right what's the expected
per ride earning this is not constant
because again the polite earning depends
on when you got the right but
it's the expected Polaroid earning
divided by the expected time they spent
in getting that entire ride which is the
right time but also the time they waited
for the right because they're not being
employed by the company they're actually
this is a loss for them if you are
waiting for a long time to get a ride
you're not making any money in that
thing and then sort of appropriately
normalized so the lambda over here the
lambda in our previous picture is really
coming about as a result of an
equilibrium computation which depends on
the average performance of this queuing
network make this okay so that's sort of
the complete model so this is the
passenger side this is sort of embedded
in a queue and then the drivers are
making endogenous entry decisions based
on what's the average performance of the
system which is affected by the driver
entry decision so if you are why I
mentioned the server oshiete role at all
papers before it there's a sense in
which they really try to capture the
same thing but they sort of capture it
using these exogenous functions they
just say this is the utility function
whereas what we are doing is we are
saying well no in order to talk about
dynamic pricing I really need to
understand the dynamics to determine
what the utility function is what the
correct equilibrium to look at and what
we want to study just to keep things
simple as we want to look at the
throughput of the system and see what we
can say about it
so again sort of to summarize um this is
the problem which I want to look at I
want to sort of think about how I design
pricing policies so as to control this
equilibrium where the passenger arrival
rate depends on the price they see when
they enter the driver arrival rate
depends on the average value they get
per ride and sort of put this entire
thing together and see what I can say
about it so yeah pause here because that
was a lot so any questions about
questions commands criticisms minor
criticisms things which can't be taken
offline
good okay um okay so what can we say
about this um so we want to look at the
pricing policy and how it affects the
could it be okay good yes this system
allow you to put a large center to tell
you when the price meets a certain point
for the driver or the where the
passenger or is it can you say that
again I didn't get that system allow and
I don't know if this is a setup system
where it's designed is it allowed to put
in alerts to the driver or the passenger
yes yes so uber does not do it for
passengers they do sort of tell you
something like it's prime time right now
but we can send you an alert if the
prime time prices reduce I have never
successfully seeing it reduce but then I
don't use uber too much does that effect
I mean it just sort of makes things more
complicated so I we can extend this a
little bit and say something like well I
can give you an average wait time till
you get a ride or an average time till
you get the correct price you want I am
pretty sure in so what I'm going to do
very soon again because I do queueing
theory I'm going to scale the system in
a certain way the thing that you're
mentioning is going to get washed out in
the scaling so the sort of effects I'm
looking for are kind of much larger
scale effects than what you're asking
for so that can be modeled it's going to
wash out in this scaling but it
definitely has an impact so in no way am
I telling you this is the optimal design
which is exactly what is used this is
kind of a thought experiment to
understand why is dynamic pricing
working this finan if you had those
mechanisms they would actually attract
drivers they definitely try that so it's
quite likely but I don't think it will
change the first-order effect of the
platform but I will say I haven't the
question about giving alerts to
passengers I have thought a bit about
and that won't effect for drivers I
haven't thought about it but I think it
won't effect
but but that to be completely fair it's
not in this model so sure
anything it's okay so they said okay we
can show that that equilibrium exists
under some conditions it's unique so we
can do the sort of due diligence on this
um it's not I don't have a formula for
what the equilibrium is of the system
but I can at least okay I can compute it
numerically and so what I will try to
show you is what we can say numerically
and a particular limit under which we
can actually understand the system which
is I'm going to scale both lambda and mu
up to infinity and then sort of rescale
the number of right so one way of
thinking about it is I'd look at this
video of this lift system I run it play
it faster and faster and then sort of
rescale it back and in that limit I can
actually say something and optimize the
system so that's what I'll try to show
you and I'll try to show that to you in
pictures so what I'm showing here is the
static pricing and what's going on here
is I'm actually using a single price and
trying to find the equilibrium number of
drivers or the equilibrium rate of rides
in the system if the price is too low
drivers don't want to work if the price
is too high passengers are now upset and
actually the driver idle time is going
up and so you get this sort of
complicated looking diagram as you just
vary the price and you can play you can
basically now scale this system by
scaling in and renormalize it and you
sort of get these our sequence of curves
and remarkably in the limit you can
actually exactly characterize what this
equilibrium looks like and what it looks
like is it looks like the minimum of two
functions one of which is determined by
supply one of which is determined by
demand if you were an economist at this
point you should turn your head this way
and look at it from this way this is
exactly a demand supply curve I didn't
set out to try and get a demand supply
curve this was just sort of coming out
from the natural micro foundation so
once we got this we were like okay in
some sense maybe we are doing something
right this seems to make sense this is
what we would expect what can we say
about dynamic pricing in this setting so
I can play the same game again so in the
case of dynamic pricing now it's two
variables the two prices so I'm doing
this two prices single threshold what
I'm showing in this plot is I'm sort of
choosing one of the prices fixed over
here
1.75 and I'm varying the second price
over this range sort of in the
background choosing an appropriate
threshold and then I'm finding the
equilibrium so you get some weird funky
shape different from the static pricing
it exactly meets the static pricing when
the two prices are equal so it seems
reasonable and I can play the same game
of scaling up the system observe what's
happening as I'm scaling it up it seems
like the sort of maximum is getting
closer and you can keep playing this
game and sort of lo and behold at the
limit the maximum values actually
collapse so the throughput the best
throughput that you get under dynamic
pricing and at least with this one
single price seems to collapse exactly
to the best throughput that you get
under static no we did not I was
actually really disappointed when I saw
this initially I thought this was just
the simulation I kept trying it with a
bunch of other cases because I expected
a phase transition here but lo and
behold you can sort of go back and show
under a very minor condition that this
one of these functions has a increasing
hazard rate this is actually
fundamentally true so you have a sort of
collapse where the dynamic pricing
collapses to a single static price in
the limit this is nice as a theorist
it's extremely disappointing as someone
who designed the system and said dynamic
pricing does really well I've been here
I'm coming back and signa no hold on a
second it doesn't do really well so
what's going on yeah why this happens or
why okay so I like that you didn't ask
why is this not obvious so so what is
going on so when I'm scaling the system
both my prices the expected price is
changing because I'm sort of doing all
these funky scaling of like fixing the
two prices but changing the threshold
but also my delays are changing now we
know that whenever the system is stable
the system firstly has to be stable
because if it's not the delay blows up
to infinity and drivers aren't happy so
that's kind of clear so it's clear that
the delay sort of going to zero at a
certain rate but on the other hand the
price may also be decreasing so it's not
obvious that when I shall scale both of
them jointly this is collapsing to a
single price but
it turns out now if you look at the surf
hazard rate condition the extra value
that I get so whenever I am sort of
using the two prices really what's
happening in the limit is the system
just oscillates very fast about the
threshold
it just keeps bouncing back and forth
between that single threshold whenever
it goes too high the delay increases but
the price also increases then it gets
pulled back delay decreases price
decreases but under this condition these
two exactly balance out and that I have
no intuition for that seems to happen
just through the algebra so this just
genuinely was surprising for me if we
sort of got it from looking at the
simulations and then the struggling
through it and that's the best I think
Ramesh will disagree I think he has some
story about it but in some sense I don't
think I can completely explain that
aspect of it what I can explain is the
next part so what in what sense can
dynamic pricing be better so he I will
take just five more minutes so in order
to sort of be convinced of this story
you a question that one should ask at
this point is great there is this
amazing static price firstly how do i
compute it and the way I'm suggesting
you compute it is you do all these sort
of crazy equilibrium computation given
all the data secondly what is the static
price is two point seven one seven two
seven one seven some some some strange
value I can't sort of go back to people
and say you can take a ride right now as
long as you pay two point seven one
seven two seven that just won't make
sense you you there is a sense in which
you don't have complete control over
prices so so there many senses in which
even though there is this amazing static
price it just cannot be implemented but
so how can we serve formalize this
notion well one question I could ask is
what if I had some noise in my parameter
estimation so what if I thought that the
demand was actually for whatever this is
unitless I mean it's just simulations
but the demand I expected it to be for
my prediction engines told me for I sort
of set my prices that forums are sat
back and said I'm gonna earn a lot of
money or get a lot of throughput in the
meantime what happened is there was a
serve ten percent shift in my demand
either up or down what's going to happen
and this is again in the large market
limit the optimal throughput basically
just with this optimal static price just
goes off a cliff
so in some sense you're not being able
to react to the fact that you miss
calculated the demand because there is
just no degree of freedom on the other
hand what I could do is suppose you told
me that yeah I don't know the exact
demand but I know it's four plus minus
10% what I could do is I could use the
higher demand to sort of set the higher
price use the lower demand to set the
lower price and just let dynamic pricing
run and when you do that this is the
performance you get and this is again
sort of more general and sort of
formally what you can show is that if
you do dynamic pricing using even just
these two points it always achieves
something better than sort of the linear
approximation of this optimal manifold
now why is this happening this we
actually understand a little better
again what's happening here is that
dynamic pricing instead of actually
improving your system overall it's just
acting as a control device it's saying
that whenever the queue is sort of
trying to go away too far I'm pushing it
back whenever it's sort of going too low
I'm pushing it forward I don't need to
exactly know what the correct price was
just by self just mixing with these two
prices I can sort of bounce back and
forth and get the right thing and you
can do it even further even if you don't
know exactly what region to choose and
you can choose like a number of dynamic
prices and do the same thing and you'll
sort of get back results of this sort so
that's the sense in which I was saying
that what we think at least at the end
of this I mean this is in John's world
and what John was saying before this is
developing a mathematical model and
assigning a narrative to it but in some
sense it was really perplexing to us as
to why exactly is dynamic pricing doing
better and I'm not claiming this is
exactly the reason although there are
some sort of predictions this makes
which you can go back and test I wish we
had data to do that but maybe hopefully
it be soon well but it does kind of
point out that there's this vase of
stark but subtle difference as to what
we think it's doing we don't think at
least that it is fundamentally better
than just doing static pricing but it is
buying you a sort of sense of learning
on a sense of robustness
in the system and and that's really the
reason why in some sense I think this is
the right community to be answering
these questions that there is something
fundamental going on here which is
outside sort of the basic economics
there is some sort of aspect of control
of algorithms which is very fundamental
in thinking about these systems and and
that's and then many other questions you
can ask in a similar light so how does
better information displays help powder
showing people heat maps help how does
showing people these weekly things help
how does that change their decisions
what if you have longer term contracts
both lyft and uber sort of experiment
with promising drivers you'll earn a
certain amount for a small fraction of
drivers does that change things what
happens because there's competition
between lyft and uber that's completely
understood a lot of the decisions are
really made in competition kind of one
thing which I'm really interested in and
I think Neil was talking about this
earlier was that how does this interact
with older system so is the rise of lyft
and uber really going to sort of
completely destroy our public transit
mode because that in some sense we maybe
agree is not the right thing to do so
how what do these equilibria look like
when we move forward and just a host of
other questions I sort of specialized it
for ride-sharing but you can kind of ask
these same questions for many of these
dynamic marketplaces so that's what I'm
sort of interested in that's the
real-time decision problems which I
think we should be alright great so
that's all I have and you have any
questions
it's questions in the modeling
standpoint yep you basically took the
limit where you let the arrival rate get
large in a certain area taxes and
customers another thing you could do it
basically it's a tax and network in
published 50 route taxis to another
block or another part of the network
yeah and then the kind of limit you
might take will be a kind of mean field
limit and you could view this as a mean
field game definitely I was laughing
with them I think Ramesh is watching
this at some point and going I told you
so but one huge thing which is missing
out in this model is we are not modeling
ET we are not modeling the fact that the
taxi may be further away from you or
closer to you so there is no spatial
dynamics here at all that is a very very
fundamental fact or a fundamental aspect
of these ride-sharing platforms that in
fact gets even more accessor baited when
you start doing right pooling when you
can have multiple people in a ride and
you're really controlling where these
cars are located and there aren't very
good models for this so I think I was
mentioning this too I mean earlier that
even just thinking about what the
optimal matching is there's a sense in
which the heuristics which have been
used but I don't think we have a very
good sense of what's the right way to do
these so I mean this is a very ways of
preliminary this is we are nowhere close
to having an understanding of this
system like say I mean as for ad
auctions or or the electrical grid to
some extent like very very nasan system
to an extent it'll help once we get more
data and there are hopefully movements
towards doing that soon but but I think
that's a great question like what would
be the sort of correct spatial scaling
to look at what should be the size of
these stations and what can you say in
that setting yeah I don't have a good
answer for that
there's no utility function for the
consumer that's really possible we're
trying to do this really serious on
consumer so I know that's a great
question um I think that's that's
another really interesting one but so in
particular one obvious thing I can say
just in this model the rate at which I
don't see a driver or I see a high price
should affect my the reuse of that
platform moving ahead in time the high
price maybe not so much but if I don't
see a driver maybe I want to switch to
city bike it's very likely it definitely
happens again outside this model I can
say some weak things about it and so
actually the weakest thing I would say
is well the cost of opening your app and
looking for a lift is just so small the
friction is very low so it's not a
first-order effect but it's definitely
an important effect which yeah outside
this model copies like side cars if you
try to have make a more full and a
marketplace curious in your kind of
analysis is there a way this have to
compare what something that would have
the
for the same answer and for that I'd
need a model for how the passenger
reacts to being shown a menu so its this
may not be true but mine it my gut
reaction as we'd need to do more sub
behavioral modeling of the passenger
before it's definitely possible to write
long-term contracts with the driver or
or even with the passenger so the lyft
and uber have long-term contracts with
certain companies saying we will give
you so many rights users for the commute
and you get a better deal and they've
now started this thing called commute
where if you are coming in from say the
subway you can serve set up a regular
long term contract for doing that I
think those so if we had to formulate
this as optimal mechanism design
I think longer term contracts with short
term dynamics would perhaps be better
than actual dynamic mechanism design I
mean I don't know that's I guess that's
partly what Shawn was saying earlier in
the morning and it's definitely moving
that way so I we will see much more sort
of long term contracts from lyft and
uber that you can freeze your rate for
the weekend if you pay so much right now
etcetera it should be coming if it's not
I was lucky if I were trying to build a
platform for taxis it's just plain
impossible to build a platform with
static pricing the only thing you can
code is something which periodically
updates its pricing so therefore
anything you built will have dynamic
pricing at some timescale and then if I
can run my dynamic pricing if I can run
my static pricing script once a month I
can run it every five minutes as well it
seems to me to compute the optimal so
then the two things I would say is that
would be what my conclusion would be
there is no such thing as a static
pricing scheme in practice the you never
build a system with tyonne pressing C
and then the question is how complex do
I want my dynamic pricing and so the
story here is that a very simple dynamic
pricing scheme is something which tries
to be so I won't go that far it's quite
possible sort of you could do something
real-time and get better prices I do
think one big limitation at that point
is going to be people don't react
between like one point two five and one
point two seven so you will I think that
almost it's almost fundamental that you
have to have big enough jumps and so
you'll never be able to do a perfect
thing so maybe you can get a perfect mix
between two but that's really what this
is doing
regular taxi service for everything and
I slightly conflicting reasons fast is
my price yeah wit and that happens and
so that's the competition between
platform side I see you could always
just undercut the other person but it's
not static because you don't hard-code
the cost into your source code at any
any piece of code you write what the
price will be a parameter which can be
fed in so the difference between static
pricing and dynamic pricing is healthman
do you want to run a script which
modified or how often I think you guys
aren't agreeing actually so Damon just
saying it just doesn't make sense if I
was to write it from scratch today why
would I do static unless you're sort of
held a gun to my head and said do static
pricing the government says and just
whatever they're very good human
psychology of policy grams but not
modifying the price too frequently it's
not a code issue it's a a data and
policy issues so if I take that to an
extreme sister maybe last come in one
could argue what you should do is you
should have a schedule which is
published one day in advancing these are
the prices and then let people decide
that is not done and I'm sort of trying
to argue that shouldn't be done or at
least at the moment that shouldn't be
done
but then it means that it depends the
current state standing instead you can
change frequently dependent current
state then we just mean see the the
timescale zero but that's fairly I mean
by static so steady doesn't miss cons
overtime I get that smooth sup sting
though on their systems basis if you're
a programmer you went hard code because
I so it's not a static means anything is
an abstraction this is still dependent
pricing yeah so I should actually go
this state dependent dynamic pricing
versus so Stevens is pointing out I
could have a dynamic schedule over time
and that is still different from so in
terms of the system do you need to query
the number of drivers to determine your
state or can you just have a lookup
table of prices I'm saying you have to
query the number of drivers or it makes
sense to query the number of drivers
but there are yes but that driver is
gonna come back whereas I may not come
back to Google so in that just naive
sense it's a more complex stochastic is
an in some sense the taxis in the area
but I mean you yeah this bloody needs to
leave and we have to have some
discussion naturally ten minutes all the
times I thought this was the discussion
okay